After over three years of basically no change, this person's cancer, the lump,
and my breast has come to life, since losing all my weight the first year after diagnosis,
it's been very easy to feel, and it's always felt the same, the lump and the breast,
firm had rigid. Now however, it's got a small area that is hard as a rock,
and it seems to be attaching to skin visibly. It's like it's going to burst through soon.
Seems similar to the attachment that creates the inverted nipple. I'm so scared,
I don't know what to make of it. If I go to the regular doctor, they will push hard for surgery,
but there's no alternative doctor close by that I know of who would monitor it as a
open wound if I try black sand. I would feel assured it was a positive response to the MMS
protocol I've been doing this last month, except unfortunately I've also been failing at my diet a
lot recently, so could be pushing a bad change. I just don't know. Still feel great physically,
getting some new blood work and a Dutch test in about a month. Then we'll also get more
information in the meantime. I'm scared, straight back into a strict diet, LOL.
Do such changes in a lump always mean bad news. I've been looking online for a source of black
sand, but I can't find one yet. Do you have any leads for this? Also a loss as to how a doctor
might a doctor locally who can monitor the black sand. You're going to have a very difficult time
finding a local doctor who's going to monitor a black sand, topical black sand protocol,
simply because it's so infrequently done. But to answer some of these prior questions here,
is doing black sand on a breast tumor? Always the right thing to do.
My answer to that would be no. We've had multiple patients do a black sand protocol on their breast.
Over the years, some had a good experience with it, some had a bad experience with it,
or it was good for a period of time and then it just seemed to just make a mess of things. It's
very difficult to manage. You're always cleaning it. It seems like it's always coming out. It seems
often it seems never ending, which is different than doing black sand on a topical melanoma.
There's always an end point with melanoma. Though I've had people do it multiple, multiple times on
that same spot still pulling the cancer out. There always was an end point and it always in my experience
ended well. With breast cancer, it's a little bit different. It's just different in many different ways.
I don't know that black sand is the right thing to do for that reason. Secondly, black sand is not
going to have an effect on a cancer that is several millimeters below the surface. If the cancer
breaks through the skin wall and you do have an open wound, then a person theoretically could use
topical things on it. His blacks have the thing to go to right away. Well, for reasons I already
stated, it may not be. So you've got to think long and hard before you're going to do that.
The other negative black sand black sand could be very painful. Some people have done it on their
breast or on a melanoma and it had not had any pain, but it does open up the wound more and it will draw.
So there's pros and cons to doing it. So don't take that, don't take, don't make your decision thinking
that that's going to be for sure the answer and I want to find somebody to do black sand.
So that being said, on their topical things, a person could do if the cancer is near the surface,
prior to a cancer breaking through the tissue from an alternative perspective. And then last
comment on this is that I would caution anybody that is in this situation, just this person who wrote
this is to not, you know, I'd question, you know, why are you completely against doing anything,
standards of care wise. Of course, standards of care in this situation, depending on how big the
masses there's all sorts of dependings there, I would want to do a mastectomy. Now, I know there's
a lot of women that are completely 100% against doing mastectomy, but we've had people that have
been that way and have done black sand and fought it for months to years and then finally succumbed
to doing a mastectomy. And you'd have to ask these people directly, do you wish you would have just
what did a mastectomy a year ago. I don't know what their answer would be. I think everybody has to
feel like they tried everything before they did that. But the next question is, are such changes in
a lump always bad news. I would say that if the lump is getting larger or it's moving in a direction
that's growth, I would say. So I would say yes, in that sense, it's bad news. It's much, it would be
worst news if it was moving towards the chest wall. So moving towards the surface is better news
than a cancer moving towards the chest wall as far as the breast cancer goes. But yeah, maybe we should
have a consultation about this to go into depth of everything, the changes that you're seeing.
Certainly getting blood work done and it's the right thing to do to get some testing done
and also getting back on the straight and narrow and different things is a good thing to do always too.